[Musique]
la jolie soirée cinéma ça fait partie du
concept des jolies soirées qui ont été
créées par joli prod en 2019 le concept
c'est de créer une synergie en train de
triptyque bien précis c'est à dire les
acteurs culturels locaux les artistes
locaux qui ont besoin d'un espace
d'expression et proposer un spectacle
aux habitants et en créant cette
synergie là on va proposer des moments
assez uniques et inédits ici le
triptyque il est autour de la thématique
du cinéma avec la salle du cratère à
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines des
réalisateurs de 50 ans en Yvelines et
également des réalisateurs et
réalisatrices de Rambouillet territoire
qui vont venir chacun présenter leurs
court-métrages
ce qu'il faut retenir de cette
programmation c'est qu'elle est 100%
locale vous allez découvrir des courts
métrages fait par des habitants par des
artistes du territoire parfois amateurs
parfois semi-professionnel bref pour
certains c'est la première fois qui vont
diffuser leur court-métrage donc ça il
faut le retenir il faut également savoir
que vous allez pouvoir échanger avec eux
autour du cinéma
[Musique]
c'est très simple c'est parce que c'est
un moment qui est assez privilégié assez
unique on est sur la deuxième édition de
jolies soirées cinéma la première avait
eu lieu au grenier à sel à Trappes donc
dans une autre salle locale là cette
fois on est au cratère à
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines il faut venir
parce que c'est des courts-métrages que
peut-être vous allez voir une seule fois
certains tournent en festival vous
n'êtes pas près de les revoir et c'est
surtout un moment qu'on ne voit pas tous
les jours
[Musique]